the heat it's also burning your money
with AC crank and all summer long and
especially during these heat waves 8
News Now weather reporter Mary Jane
beliesza has some energy saving tips
that could help you from Breaking the
Bank
Lacey Coulson is a Southwest Valley
homeowner she says her electric bills
are the highest from July to September
so because I know that I try to do
little things that'll help it and then I
also know that I'll be paying a little
bit more so I save up a little extra my
typical electric bill is normally around
300 350 but in these three months it
goes up to around 600. she's made a few
adjustments around her home I just do
things that are the obvious ways I just
try not to use power as much as I can
during the day we also use the quick
settings in our like if we're going to
do a load of laundry we do like the
quick setting instead of the long one
same with the dishwasher according to
Envy energy these simple steps can
potentially save you 10 to 25 percent on
your monthly bill NV Energy advises you
to save money by allowing dishes to air
dry in the dishwasher and keep the heat
out by closing the Kearns or shutters NV
Energy says you can set your thermostat
to 78 or 80 degrees when at home or five
degrees warmer when you're not at home I
think it definitely saves a couple
hundred dollars just by those little
little differences the most energy
efficient time is to run the dishwasher
washing machine and dryer at night or
before eight in the morning Mary Jane
beliesa 8 news now NV Energy provides
free energy Assessments in your home or
business to help you become energy
efficient they also provide smart
thermostats which can help you save a
hundred bucks on each of your energy
bills each and every year